concernant la faire une loi est ce que
vous est ce que vous le saviez moi j'ai
su à partir de la ferme aux pins qui
avait quelque chose parce que dans l'
enquête qui a eu lieu pour nous ni pour
notre affaire il y avait une phrase
d'une personne que j'ai eu à la fin
l'enquète quand j'ai eu tous les pv des
t notés qu'elle ne voulait pas déposé
plainte contre denis baupin parce
qu'elle avait connu pire ailleurs à la
fondation hulot donc c'est sympa à
partir de ce moment avec moi j'ai eu une
espèce de d' alerte en disant qu'il
s'est passé dans cette fondation que
vous avez essayé d'en savoir plus alors
mais il ya eu enquête d'hebdos dans
quelques semaines après c'est donc je
leur ai donné ce pv là pour qu'ils
voient enfin la partie du pv là dessus
pour qu'ils aient la preuve est qu'ils
enquêtent donc c'est comme ça que j'ai
participé à la première enquête il était
pro pour protéger selon vous
manifestement oui c'est à dire beaucoup
à partir de 2018 à partir du moment où
l'hebdo sort et où il y à des fêtes dans
cet article tout le monde le protège
tout le monde le gouvernement met en
place une stratégie pour le protéger et
par des membres d'europe écologie aussi
il pas être partout ceux qui ont lu ce
alors europe écologie se trouve que ont
il paraît qu'ils n'ont plus inviter tous
et moi j'étais plus dans le parti mais
il paraît qu'il mène plus invité à
partir de ce moment là donc eu je pense
pas qu'on puisse leur faire ce procès là
mais par contre il ya plein de gens qui
l'ont protégé enfin je veux dire quand
on a une ministre de l'égalité femme
homme qui écrit
non c'est pas l âge at il dit à des
ordres mais les ordres mais j'ai sa
réponse à marlène schiappa l'est que
j'ai eue aujourd'hui par téléphone avant
de vous recevoir
et c'est vrai que marlène l aeem dit
dans le timing elle n'était pas très
proche de nicolas hulot elle voit sa lé
est laissé pour l'instant le faire un
truc elle fait une première action
depuis là elle me dit quand il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup trop de points que
j'ai fait une réaction qui était à la
hauteur de 2,2 des
débats des guides de l'atrocité de tout
ce qu'on peut voir ou de tout ce qu'on
peut entendre non d'accord mais dit il
est charmant
dit pas on dit pas non non qui vient
d'avoir un des articles dans la vidéo
une écharpe abdou alors après midi après
donc penser qu'au gouvernement passe
comme il y avait une grosse place au
gouvernement il était
scanner deux
numéros 3 je vais vous donner un exemple
quand il ya la sphère cahuzac il ya deux
enquêtes parlementaires ça veut dire
qu'il ya deux enquêtes par l'europe
cahuzac il doit répondre à deux enquêtes
parlementaires pensent avoir pour
répondre des faits pour poser pour
répondre aux questions qui sont posées
par le monde par les parlementaires là
il ya eu aucune enquête parlementaire
quand il y avait là une d'un journal
racistes sur taubira jean marc ayrault
qui est le premier ministre saisi le
parquet pourquoi la personne n'a saisi
ni le parquet ni une enquête
parlementaire l'ont laissé qu'en fait on
n'a pas cherché à savoir ce qui s'était
passé on a cherché à sauver hulot santé
ça qui sait pas et ses rimes en moins
les gens disent que les faits sont
prescrits
oui mais non mais je vous dis parce que
juridiquement voilà voilà ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui voilà pourquoi aussi
voilà c'est peut-être passé comme c'est
ce que vous avez déjà assisté à des
comportements déplacés vous moi je crois
même je ne crois même pas avoir été dans
la même pièce que lui donc je vois pas
comment j'aurais pu être se
connaissaient pas du tout ah non non
je pense que j'avais un instant dans un
morceau de pourquoi est ce qu on
n'établit pas une loi sur
l'imprescriptibilité du viol non mais à
l'heure du viol sur mineure en tous les
cas ça me semble absolument
indispensable non mais là moi je pense
qu'il manque un truc royal mail fait pas
partie du gouvernement pour l'instant je
n'en mets en tant qu homme femme
politique oui mais bon mais c'est pas
d'essai non mais là il manque un truc en
fait dans la vie politique c'est que
dans la vie politique quand il ya des
élus ou des personnalités politiques qui
sont accusés par des femmes qui y pas
qu'ils mettent une parole dans l'espace
public il manque une espèce de haute
autorité comme il y en a une pour
l'argent se dire que si à partir du
moment où il ya un soupçon que vous
voler de l'argent il ya tout de suite
une enquête qui se met en place et la
haute autorité pour la transparence dans
la vie publique et on a vu avec fillon
le scandale qu'avait fait l'histoire de
ces costumes là on a quand même un
ministre qui est accusé de viol et
laissé plus grave d'avoir des costumes
gratuits que de violer une femme
manifestement non on a quand même un
problème de salle on a un problème de
violence vis-à-vis des femmes qui n'est
pas reconnue dans la société aujourd'hui
jean-louis vous dit tout lorsqu'on est
bien quelqu'un on le protège même si la
cuisine non non j'ai dit
jamais pourriez-vous dire ah non je
crois pas non non non non je crois pas
m'être c'est qu'ils ont posées c'est ce
qui s'est passé
mais je pense que le réflexe spontané
c'est de protéger celui qui est accusé
et de déligitimer la parole des femmes
si fière de dire aux femmes non vous
montez c'est un complot ce que vous
dites est faux il n'y a pas de preuve
c'est presque rayés est en fait toutes
ces phrases là c'est des phrases qui
sont en fait des phrases terrorisante
pour les femmes qui n'ont pas encore
parlé c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre